I wrote a book from 1984 to 1999 called
maps of meaning and a lot of the things
I talk about come out of all the reading
I did during that period because I was
reading an insane amount and thinking
really nonstop 16 hours a day.
Like the only way I could stop myself
from thinking was to go work out with
weights.
I couldn't shut off by my concern with
the issues that I was dealing with and I
was spending about three hours a day
writing and I did that everyday for 15
years and that was the consequences.
That was the book.
And
the writing also helped a tremendous
amount because it helps clarify your
thinking,
writing,
you know,
because actually you're smarter when you,
right?
Because you can externalize
your thoughts and then you can,
you can use your working memory to
analyze what you've written instead of
remembering the thought.
And so you're,
you're externalizing your memory.
You can analyze what you thought,
you can refine it,
you can reorder it.
You can edit like mad
with a word processor,
which is also a very new thing to it.
Editing is very difficult.
If you have to do that with pen
and paper with a typewriter,
it's like,
forget it.
You,
you get your first draft and that's it.